we're getting our first look now at the
moments after a crash that killed two
children in North Las Vegas last week
thanks for joining us I'm Denise Valdez
I'm Kirsten Joyce we're going to show
you video from the officer's body camera
some of these images are disturbing
hey stop touching the child you're going
to cause more harm than there is done
already do you understand
[Music]
the first officer you're hearing from
arriving found the two women and the
children one child had already passed
away at the scene as we know both women
were taken to the hospital arrested
while in their hospital beds here's some
video of the mother's arrest
you're actually being placed under
arrest right now
okay you were under arrest for felony
child abuse and neglect resulting in
death for your two kids
[Music]
okay we're going to have Correctional
staff be present with you at all times
until you're medically cleared and then
you'll be transported to the north Las
Vegas jail
a vigil held Saturday night for the two
children
both women the mother of the children
and their aunt received numerous
injuries in the crash that's why they've
been in the hospital